hi I want to welcome you here I'm Ellen
lost in the Department of Political
Science and it's my great pleasure today
to welcome Hillary Leverett who we've
had the pleasure of having with us this
year teaching in the Jackson Institute
also being just a great colleague and
member of the community so it's a great
great pleasure to welcome you Hillary
and to give you a bit so for those of
you who don't know about her a bit of
background Hillary grant graduated from
harvard law school as well as from
brandeis university but she's also
studied at the American University of
Cairo and at Tel Aviv so she's had a
long two decade now history of
experience and interaction and expertise
on the region she's a CEO of strategy
and she's been a news analyst trail
Jazeera English which I saw her on not
long ago and also a national security
expert blogger for the National Journal
under the George W Bush administration
she served as the director for iran
afghanistan and persian gulf affairs at
the National Security Council she was
the direct the Middle East specialist on
the Security Secretary of State's policy
planning staff as well as a political
advisor for the Middle East Central
Asian and African issues for the US
mission to the United Nations from 2001
into two 2003 and I think particularly
important for the the topic that should
be dressing today she was one of a small
number of US diplomats who was
authorized to negotiate with the
Iranians over Afghanistan al Qaeda and
Iraq before in Indian Clinton
administration I'm sorry she served as a
political advisor for the Middle East
Central Asian African issues for the US
mission as well to the United Nations as
associate director for the Near Eastern
affairs at the National Security Council
and a special assistant to the
ambassador at the US Embassy in Cairo in
short she knows the region well she
knows Iran probably as well or better
than than others in the in the States
and we're very very welcoming of her
today just to now give a bit of a plug
because I also know and understand I've
just heard this was up on amazon.com she
and her husband Flynt Leverett are also
the authors of a
forthcoming book calling called entitled
going to Tehran why why the United
States must come to terms with the
Islamic Republic and not surprisingly
she's here to talk to us today about
Iran the United States and the Middle
East changing balance of power so
welcome Hillary I think when we look at
the Middle East many of us are looking
at what we see on the ground in the
Middle East and some have called it this
momentous change an Arab Awakening
really a bottom-up phenomenon a dramatic
manifestation of people power there are
many good reasons to look at what's
happening in the Middle East I think
from this perspective but for me as
someone who is focused on u.s. foreign
policy and international strategy I'm
looking at and interpreting what's going
on in the Middle East from a different
angle from another angle that I want to
go through with you today and that is
from the breakdown of the us-led
political and security order in the
Middle East essentially what i see is a
potential collapse of us hegemony in the
region to look at the events that we see
unfolding on the ground from this angle
it's important to step back it's
important to step back and look at the
Middle East really from the end of World
War two as the United States gradually
but steadily trying to establish this
kind of political and security order in
the Middle East that would be favorable
to our interests we gradually unsteadily
did so but of course along the way from
the end of World War two to the collapse
of the Soviet Union we were constrained
from going for really what i would call
all-out hegemony in the Middle East by a
major external power at the time the
Soviet Union and two internal powers to
major internal powers in the region
aligned with Moscow those were Iraq and
Egypt fast forward a bit too 1978 Egypt
moves decisively out of the Soviet camp
decisively into the pro-american camp in
the Middle East literally signed sealed
and delivered with the
david accords with the peace treaty with
israel there could have been no
mistaking the movement of Egypt so
decisively into the pro-american camp
and even though a year later we
essentially lost Iran from the
pro-american camp Iran did not go to the
Soviets it do not defect to the other
side it was so consumed by its internal
political reconstitution and literally
defending the country from an invasion
coming from Iraq that it was not an
effective constrain ER on this
increasingly us-led political and
security order in the Middle East and by
1991 we essentially took care of the
other internal constraint potential
internal constraint for American
hegemony in the Middle East Iraq when we
dealt Iraq a decisive military defeat
after invaded Kuwait in 1990 so with the
subsequent collapse of the Soviet Union
clearly done by the end of 1991 end of
1991 we were essentially unconstrained
in the 1990s going into the 1990s in
both our ability and our determination
to consolidate hegemony in the Middle
East and again by this I mean really a
highly militarized us-led political and
security order for the region today what
we're seeing is that disappearing right
before our eyes what we're seeing in the
Middle East today is a dramatic shift in
the regional balance of power a shift in
the relative distribution of power going
against the United States and our
regional and our regional powers
partners and increasingly going in favor
of the Islamic Republic of Iran and its
allies this shift though has been going
on I'd say from probably more than a
decade had been going on for more than a
decade one of the most important
consequences that we see with the Arab
Awakening today that is unfolding today
is an acceleration and intensification
this shift in the regional balance and
beyond the shift in the relative
distribution of power among important
regional actors the very essence of
power politics in the Middle East is
shifting from hard military power where
the United States has the advantage just
soft power where the Islamic Republic of
Iran has unique advantages but I want to
look with you first at the shift in the
relative distribution of power among the
important regional actors just a decade
ago on the eve of 911 on the eve of the
terrorist attacks 911 in the United
States the United States had cultivated
what I think American policymakers like
to refer to as a strong moderate
quote-unquote moderate camp in the
Middle East now these so-called
moderates were never defined as such
because of their internal governance or
anything about the way that they dealt
with their people these states were
so-called moderates termed as part of
the martyr moderate camp because they
were reasonably well disposed towards
strategic cooperation with the United
States including a negotiated peace
settlement with Israel these states
included Egypt Jordan the Gulf states
Morocco Tunisia and Turkey on the other
side of the Middle East divided where
the so-called radicals and again called
radicals not because of anything that
had to do with their internal governance
but because of their position toward us
and Israeli policies that camp that
alliance of groups and countries
included the Islamic Republic of Iran
Syria and at the time the relatively
weak groups of Hezbollah and Hamas at
the time the other radicals on the scene
Saddam Hussein's Iraq and Qadhafi's
Libya were essentially isolated now
let's fast-forward to the eve of
President Obama's inauguration in
January 2009
january 2009 you could look out at the
region and i think you would see that as
a result of the US invasion of iraq the
effect of collapse of the Middle East
peace process astute politicking and
diplomacy by the Islamic Republic of
Iran and its allies because of these
issues the Middle East balance of power
before Obama even stepped foot in the
Oval Office the Middle East balance of
power had already shifted significantly
against the United States and our
regional allies and toward the Islamic
Republic of Iran and again that's even
before he steps foot in the oval office
in January 2009 I want to go through
with you for a moment what that looked
like on the ground in the Middle East
relations between Syria and Islamic
Republic of Iran were increasingly
strategic in their fallen II they had
moved from my thing largely a tactical
alliance in the 1990s to one of real
strategic significance for both
countries which have made attempts to
pull Syria away from the Islamic
Republic of Iran really feudal turkey
under the AKP was moving away from its
reflexively pro-american stance to chart
a genuinely independent political course
foreign policy course including
cultivating a strategically
consequential relationship with the
Islamic Republic of Iran Hezbollah and
Hamas legitimated by real electoral
successes had emerged by January 2009 as
decisively important political actors in
Palestine and Lebanon post Saddam
Hussein's Iraq was looking less and less
like a potential strategic asset for the
United States and ever more likely that
it's most important relations its most
important foreign relations would be
with its neighbors with the Islamic
Republic of Iran Syria and Turkey what
was driving this shift in the Middle
East balance of power to answer that I
think it's important to look first at
the basis for us dominance in the middle
dazed us dominance in the Middle East
has rested I think on two principal
factors capacity and legitimacy first
regarding capacity the United States
remains uniquely capable of projecting
enormous amounts of conventional
military power into the Middle East no
one else not even China can project this
kind of hard conventional military power
into the Middle East today and no one
else will be able to do so for years to
come this unique capacity to project
massive conventional military power into
the Middle East was used of course to
justify our two interventions with Iraq
in and with Iraq and today is the
precise verbatim word for word
justification that President Obama has
used to justify our most recent military
intervention in Libya because the United
States has the unique capabilities to do
so but the prolonged strategically
indeterminate us occupations in
Afghanistan and Iraq I think have
underscored the limits of what US
military might can accomplish and I
would venture to predict we will see
that unfold in Libya as well regarding
legitimacy the United States has tried
under successive presidential
administrations under the first George
Bush 41 President Clinton second George
Bush 43 and now President Obama we have
tried under successive presidential
administrations to gain the buy-in of
Arab states for what I started out
describing to you as this us-led highly
militarized political and security order
in the Middle East but I think little
political scientist is commonly referred
to as hegemony we've tried to get their
buy-in the Arab states buy-in for this
political and security order on the
grounds that US leadership in the region
would bring good things to the Middle
East it would bring the people
the region greater security and a
resolution of the region's core dispute
the arab-israeli conflict but the facts
are the United States has not delivered
on these promises the US military
campaigns in Afghanistan and Iraq have
instead cost us cost us in terms of our
perceived legitimacy and the perceived
legitimacy of our very purpose of being
in the Middle East likewise it has
become increasingly clear to Middle East
populations that the United States is
not going to deliver on arab-israeli
peace we're not going to deliver the
Israelis to the table and we're not
going to deliver an end to that poor
conflict instead the United States today
is widely seen in the Middle East as
enabling an Israeli national security
doctrine that work requires regional
hegemony for Israel as well as for the
United States but in this context really
for Israel with the means of permanent
occupation and the freedom for Israel to
use military force unilaterally and
disproportionately and people throughout
the Middle East don't see any end in
sight for that this too has cost the
united states in terms of the perceived
legitimacy of our very purpose in the
Middle East what i would call these
failures these failures did not start
with george w bush i don't think they
were idiosyncratic or ideologically
generated products of just his
administration the drive to consolidate
hegemony in the Middle East threw open
the open-ended deployment of large
numbers of u.s. military forces on the
ground in the Middle East and I think
what today really needs to be called the
facade of a Middle East peace process
that really starts at the end of the
Cold War at the end of the first Gulf
War under President the first president
Bush 41 and it intensified under
President Clinton to a large extent
president george w bush 43 carriage of
their logical conclusions conclusion
policies that were started under his two
immediate predecessors Bush 41 and
Clinton
during the presidential campaign of 2008
then-candidate obama pledged to change
all that he changed he pledged to change
the very foundation of our policies in
the Middle East to put them on a more
effective and sustainable trajectory in
Iraq in Afghanistan in the arab-israeli
arena and really in an innovative way in
a particularly in a presidential
campaign to try strategic engagement
with the Islamic Republic of Iran
instead however my view is that today
President Obama is presiding over what I
see as the very demise of the two-state
solution to the israeli-palestinian
conflict he is turning the United States
into a quasi permanent occupying power
in Afghanistan by surging additional
troops into that country with no
strategy for a political settlement
there and he's discredited engagement as
a strategy for dealing with Iran and for
others by saying he tried but failed to
reach out to the Islamic Republic of
Iran when I think the record shows that
he didn't seriously even try this
dynamic is playing out today with Libya
as well the dominant image is of a
qaddafi who is irrational and in some
ways just downright evil but the facts
are that the United States negotiated
successfully with this same marma
Qaddafi we negotiated with him on high
priority issues like weapons of mass
destruction and links to terrorist
groups and the record shows that in
those negotiations Qaddafi could act
rationally and US interests and a way
that benefited the United States in very
real tangible ways but here again what
President Obama did when faced with a
choice is that he foreclosed any
negotiations with with Qaddafi with limb
just as effectively as he is he has
foreclosed negotiations with the Islamic
Republic of Iran he did so with Qaddafi
on March third by declaring that Qaddafi
had lost all legitimacy and had to go
from that moment on from March third on
we were on a trajectory for military
conflict with Libya it was just a matter
of when imagine for a moment if Nixon or
Kissinger had said these things about
China's Chairman Mao in the late 1960s
and early 1970s where would us-china
relations be today what would America's
position in Asia be like today if we had
adopted that kind of policy this in
large part I think is why in the Middle
East the balance of power is shifting
even further away from the United States
on Obama's watch and white shifting
further away from the United States and
increasingly toward the Islamic Republic
of Iran that has a better narrative for
populations in the Middle East what the
Islamic Republic of Iran has done all
this time is continued to deepen its
alliances with Syria with Turkey explant
expand its influence with groups and
populations in Iraq in Lebanon and
Palestine its allies in these we in
these in these areas have consolidated
their standing in their regional arenas
as the most influential political actors
in the region that's how the Islamic
Republic of Iran is shifting the balance
of power on their side in their favor an
Obama is standing by for the most part
of course with the exception of Libya
but he's standing by otherwise as new
openings develop for the Islamic
Republic of Iran to reset the regional
balance of power emerging to reset it in
places like Bahrain and perhaps even
Egypt Tunisia Yemen and other places as
I just flagged I think the one place
where he's not stood by is in Libya
where of course President Obama has
ordered US military intervention in what
may be characterized as a civil
war on the ground there for the United
States to be on one side on the side of
the rebels against the Libyan government
and its supporters I think President
Obama tonight will try to make a case
but this is because of a sober analysis
of on the ground conditions I think we
should really challenge that as
Americans I don't think that President
Obama will be able to tell the American
people for example how many civilians
Gaddafi's forces have killed in this
round of protests I don't even think
you'll get be able to give a rough
estimate the estimates vary dramatically
I think President Obama will refer to
what might have happened in Benghazi if
we haven't if we didn't intervene
militarily but when he does that he will
ignore the record of how Qaddafi has
responded to past uprisings in Libya
including in the Benghazi region of
course any loss of life is terrible but
those interventions did not lead to the
dots of tens of thousands of people and
did not leave the mass migration of
Libyans to Egypt which is what Secretary
Clinton claimed yesterday when she was
on the Sunday morning shows what this
will effectively define I think for
President Obama what he will I think
effectively to find this evening is a
doctrine of preventive humanitarian
intervention it will be a very close
analogue if not just a direct supplement
to President Bush's bush 43 s
endorsement of preventive war so that
means the United States will now have
preventive war as its strategy not just
to deal with weapons of mass destruction
links to al-qaeda but now we'll have
this component of what if there might be
a humanitarian problem disaster or I
think as Secretary Clinton put it
yesterday the potential for instability
from this perspective I think that
Obama's course is at best strategically
incoherent and I think the real motive
really is desperation desperation to
reverse perceptions that US influence in
the United States is now in free fall
think that perception is well-founded
that US influence in the Middle East now
is in freefall because the facts are
what they are all of the Middle Eastern
regimes that have been seriously
challenged by sustained a popular unrest
are either close American allies Bahrain
Egypt Tunisia and Yemen or former rogue
states that made complete deals to go
into the pro-american camp like Libya
that is the pattern I don't think that
what we're seeing happening in Syria
fundamentally alters this pattern at
this point the manifestations of popular
unrest that we've seen in Syria are not
large enough or broad-based enough to
pose a real threat to the government
that might change but Bashar al-assad
the president of Syria's assiduous
cultivation of an independent foreign
policy line that grounds popular
perceptions among Syrians that their
country is not subordinate to the United
States Israel or any other outside power
gives Bashar al-assad important
political resources he can draw on to
help manage the challenge he faces that
is something that is not available to
these other countries that where we see
sustained popular unrest it makes me
even more strongly persuaded that
Western speculation that the wave of
popular unrest we've seen throughout the
Middle East that has literally
overwhelmed the pro-american Arab
regimes there it makes me very very
speculative that that kind of unrest
could really sees and take hold of and
overthrow the government in the Islamic
Republic of Iran I think that is wishful
thinking why is this I've taken a lot of
criticism for this view but since
literally the day after the Islamic
Republic of Iran's presidential
elections in june 2009
I have argued that the opposite the
Iranian opposition grieve green movement
does not represent anything close to a
majority of Iranian Society inside Iran
and that the majority of Iranians inside
Iran continue to support the idea of an
Islamic Republic there and today I think
the opposition grieve movement in Iran
represents an even smaller portion of
Iranian Society than it did in the
summer of two thousand nine when it had
an immediate grievance around which to
rally protest moreover efforts to
restart protests in the Islamic Republic
of Iran have taken place and what I
think most most Iranians inside Iran see
is their moment in the Middle East this
is the time when the regional balance of
favor is shifting the regional balance
of power is shifting in their favor it's
their movement that decreases the amount
of political space available for the
green movement to put out its message
and again I think the popular sense of
Independence is really important to
these dynamics the overwhelming majority
of Iranians even those who want the
Islamic Republic of Iran to evolve in
ways very different from its current
state who want to see very significant
reforms in the Islamic Republic even
among those Iran ians the vast majority
I think see the Islamic Republic of Iran
has their system their indigenously
created system warts and all this is a
very important part of why the Islamic
Republic in my view has defied
conventional wisdom and not only
survived throughout the past 30 years of
repeated predictions that it will
implode and collapse not only survive
those predictions but strengthened to
the extent that the Islamic Republic of
Iran can now balance effectively against
the United States in what is now a
competition for influence in the Middle
East so I come back to my point that the
relative distribution
power in the Middle East is shifting it
is shifting away from the United States
and our allies and increasingly to the
Islamic Republic and its partners in the
resistance can in this context Iranian
policymakers I think are confident and I
think with good reason that any
government in the Arab world which
becomes at all more representative of
its people's values beliefs concerns
preferences and interests any government
in the Arab world that becomes more
representative of that will become less
enthusiastic about strategic cooperation
with the United States and Israel and
that is a net plus for the Islamic
Republic of Iran as long as the current
regimes in the Middle East are not
replaced by stridently Sunni Salafi
dominated Islamists orders like we see
in some some ways in Saudi Arabia or the
Taliban in Afghanistan as long as these
regimes don't turn into those kinds of
Islamist political orders the Arab
governments that emerge from the present
turmoil will follow I think an
independent foreign policy line and on
the whole that will create greater
receptivity to the Islamic Republic of
Iran's message of independence and
resistance this message does not just
apply to Shiite Muslims public opinion
polls and just the experience of
spending time on the ground in these
societies in the Middle East indicate
that the message of resistance resonates
throughout the region and has tremendous
appeal not just to Shia but on the Sunni
Arab on the Sunni Arab Street an Iran
calculates that this will work in its
favor Iran doesn't have to meddle in
regional politics the Islamic Republic
of Iran can sit on its hands and reap
these benefits the regional balance of
power is also shifting at another very
and level it is shifting in the very
essence of Middle East power politics on
this level the critical point is that
the balance of power in the Middle East
is becoming relatively less defined by
hard military capabilities and
quantifiable economic indicators and
relatively more defined in terms of a
balance of influence in the Middle East
here it's important to discuss soft
power soft power of course famously
defined by Harvard University's Joseph
Nye as the capacity of getting others to
want what you want contrasted with the
ability to coerce others through the
exercise of hard military and or
economic power one of the most
remarkable things about the shift in the
Middle East balance of power over the
last decade away from the United States
and our allies and increasingly in favor
of the Islamic Republic of Iran and its
partners is that this shift has had
virtually nothing nothing to do with
military capabilities or other forms of
hard power it's quite astounding it's
very much about soft power and the fact
that the Islamic Republic of Iran has
picked winners including regional
public's rather than losers as its
political allies and key regional
theaters throughout the Middle East to
do this Iran is cultivated an expanding
reservoir of soft power it's soft power
is derived from its support for
resistance movements on the front lines
of the arab-israeli conflict and in its
defiance it's very defiance of the
United States and other Western powers
over the nuclear issue for the last
decade or so and i would say especially
since President Ahmadinejad's initial
election to the presidency in 2005 the
Islamic Republic of Iran has worked to
maximize the strategic leverage it
derives from its soft power edge in
particular the Islamic Republic of Iran
has used its standing as the de facto
leader of the Middle East resistance
block to mobilize regional public's most
intensely felt grievances including
those grievances against the United
States and Israel and the region's
pro-western regimes many Western
analysts dismiss the significance of
this soft power particularly in the
coldly competitive venue of Middle
Eastern power politics but the kind of
soft power that the Islamic Republic has
been able to cult generate and cultivate
has had real world impact former
national security adviser is big
Brzezinski I think has written with
particular insight about something here
what he describes as a global political
awakening in which nearly universal
access to radio TV the internet is
creating a community of shared
resentments and envy that transcends
sovereign borders in the Middle East and
other regions that are scarred by
memories of colonial and imperial
domination this is generating a yearning
for human dignity and cultural respect
among local populations consequently
some these same populations disliking of
the status quo can be mobilized against
those whom they perceive as self
interestingly preserving the status quo
the quintessential example of this is
the United States and its relationship
with President Mubarak in Egypt the
Iranian policymakers even before
Brzezinski made his observation I think
fundamentally grasped the potential for
Middle Eastern populations mobilized
against the status quo to challenge
existing regimes to challenge a regional
order dominated by the United States and
to challenge a regional balance of power
tilted very significantly against the
Islamic Republic of Iran what they
developed was a real strategy
what the Iranian Iranian strategy
developed was a real strategy one might
even say grand strategy but as Americans
we have invested so much mental energy
and political capital in demonizing the
Islamic Republic of Iran that we haven't
been able to recognize the extent than
the amount of what they are
accomplishing in strategic terms the
Islamic Republic is using through its
narrative not its meddling but its
narrative it is using the political
awakening of Middle Eastern public's to
alter the very nature of power politics
in the region more specifically the
Islamic Republic of Iran is working to
transform the Middle East traditional
balance of power to transform this
traditional balance of power framework
defined by conventional military
capabilities and other hard power assets
in which the Islamic Republic of Iran is
deficient they're trying to transform
that into a balance of influence defined
by aspects of soft power in which the
Islamic Republic of Iran has some very
unique advantages this transformation is
bolstering the Islamic Republic of
Iran's ability to shape strategic
outcomes in the Middle East the u.s.
faces some very serious challenges there
our strategic position as I said from
the onset in this vital world part of
the world is eroding before our eyes to
repair and restore our standing and
strategic leadership in the Middle East
we will have to reacquire to skills at
which we have been sorely out of
practice one is the capacity to
legitimate our leadership in the Middle
East by actually delivering important
benefits to our partners they are rather
than being a contributor to the Middle
East problems the second skill we need
to we need to reacquire that we will
need to really relearn I think is the
art of classical diplomacy
meaning the art of managing a regional
balance through relationships with a
foot with the full range of important
actors cutting across multiple axes of
geopolitical alignment this will mean an
end to trying to isolate and contain
players that don't go along with our
current understanding or view of what is
pro-american or anti-american the region
it will mean developing real strategic
relations with each of the major powers
and that means starting the hard work of
a rapprochement with the Islamic
Republic of Iran just as Nixon and
Kissinger did with Chuck the people's
republic of china in the early 1970s
thank you very much for your attention
I'd be happy to have a discussion any
questions or or please I think when we
talk about the GCC it's it's of course
we it's a critical part of the Middle
East and we talked about the GCSE the
most important vital member of that
grouping is Saudi Arabia we have a long
strategic partnership with Saudi Arabia
that even if the saudi's encounter
protests which they haven't in a
sustained basis through the Arab
Awakening even if they do I think that
the relationship with Saudi Arabia will
remain a strategic one in America's
vital interests but the way that we can
more effectively manage that
relationship both for our own interests
and I think for the Saudis is to be able
to have a strategy where we have a
relationship with all of the players in
the region it's dysfunctional at this
point to have a relationship just with
saudis and not with the other major
great power across the Gulf that means
that it's constantly the u.s. versus the
Saudis in the push and pull of politics
and diplomacy whereas if we had the
relationship with Iran as we did in the
1970s and before the Iranians and the
Saudis could balance each other in the
region and we could take more of the
position of the offshore balancer only
coming into the region when their eerily
is a crisis that threatens American
vital interests for the remainder of the
time the great powers in the region
principally Saudi Arabia and Iran but
also traditionally Iraq Turkey Egypt and
probably Israel in this category if they
could be balancing each other in the
region we could be offshore but our
policy I think our dysfunctional policy
of essentially taking out and trying to
contain some of these major powers makes
us directly an onshore balancer makes us
are very important if not really
hegemonic power in the region where we
are we are effectively and we certainly
are with troops on the ground they are
to balance the other players and that
means they're always going to be doing
something against us rather than busy
doing something against each other or
trying to work out things more
constructively with each other I think
the best way that we can have a really
strategic constructive relationship with
Saudi Arabia is to balance it with a
strategic constructive relationship with
Iran and let them balance each other I
think that is really the way that you
get stability and as much peace as
possible in the region please
Thank yet so that's also a very good
question i look at the Iraq intervention
as an intervention two parts and the
first part was in 1991 legitimated then
by a UN mandate and an Arab League
mandate an Arab participation it vital
Arab participation we launched the
entire operation from Saudi Arabia and
we continue to to enforce the no-fly
zone over a rock for 12 years from Saudi
Arabia with active heavily heavy Saudi
involvement I don't see the 2003
intervention is that that deviating from
the initial intervention so to me when I
look at the two and I think if you look
at it historically and what the
consequences have been they are pretty
similar when you hear people today
saying well the Libya intervention is
new and different both because it has a
UN Security Council mandate and because
it has error participation to me it is
really a historic because we did have
that free rock we tend not to look at it
at what we had for Iraq because I think
we were so focused on the the attempt
potentially maybe you could characterize
it this way of the George W Bush
administration to turn back to Iraq when
it should have been focused on al-qaeda
but that's really a political battle
from here in the United States I don't
think it really is about the region if
you look at the intervention for Iraq I
think it really is one that you could
just say unfolds in two or three parts
the 1990-91 intervention the subsequent
no-fly zone for 12 years and then the
2003 intervention to finish it off so if
you look in it that way I think the
narratives are pretty similar and I
think that if you look at it that way
the lesson that you could take from it
is that we will not escape the blowback
and the consequences that we had from
the Iraq intervention both in terms of
regional public's turning against it
regional governments turning against it
and I think you saw that
in an almost comical way the Arab League
secretary-general remove seconda stain
24 hours of agreement before coming back
and saying well that's not exactly what
he agreed to it's amazing when you look
at what happened the in the Arab League
deliberations over Libya typically the
Arab League puts out a statement of what
they agreed at their meetings they
didn't put one out this time we don't
know who agreed to what it's quite
striking and I think we will see similar
to the Iraq intervention people having
second thoughts both among regional
publix and among regional leadership
we've been in a sense blinded by that
because we've separated the Iraq
interventions but I think we'll see that
come back and well I think we'll end up
paying some pretty severe consequences
please
right
yes
yeah two very important very very
important questions I think the the way
it's been posited to deliver on Libya to
develop to deliver essentially on behalf
of the people not just for ourselves in
terms of oil or Israel is a really
really important one something that's
resonating throughout the region but to
deliver doesn't necessarily mean and I
think actually just does not mean
delivering militarily I think that's a
false option we tried it with Iraq and
we were we were encouraged very
significantly encouraged to deliver on
Iraq by many of our Arab allies not just
in the Gulf of by a judge Hosny Mubarak
was pleading with us to deliver on Iraq
at the time Saudi Arabia was pleading
with us to deliver on Iraq at the time
but it didn't work that kind of military
intervention isn't really delivering on
behalf of the people in the region the
consequences the blowback the inevitable
on the ground occupation of the United
States has to adopt has to press to
pursue with no end in sight is not in
our interest and it's not in their
interests so I don't think I think I
think that's constantly put out as an
option for the United States but it's a
really really false one and i think one
that has done real damage the one that's
never put out and this gets to what the
one of the other points i tried to lay
out when we never entertain is we never
entertain because we've demonized these
various players that we see as against
the american-led political and security
order so wherever whenever they come up
they get demonized whether it's Iraq
under Saddam Hussein in 1990 whose
troops go into Iraq to pull babies out
of the incubators and steal the
incubators of course a lot of these
stories never are true there were cancer
after the fact of course Iraq having
nuclear weapons recanted after the fact
the demonization that happens with Iran
which makes it impossible for us to
ago she ate with a hitler like
Ahmadinejad bent on being the histories
for suicide nation these this
demonization that I think has very
little grounding in reality comes up
again with Qaddafi and so it puts us
into this false paradigm where it's
either we million termi militarily on
behalf of the population or we have no
choice but we have a choice we could
negotiate because we've demonized the
other the player that is then deemed
impossible to bring into the approaching
camp we can't negotiate with them and
that's why I think that President
Obama's March third statement the
Qaddafi had lost all legitimacy and had
to go was a really fatal strategic error
because it meant that we couldn't
negotiate with him now why couldn't we
negotiate with him okay he may not be
the most pleasant person to negotiate
with but we have a track record of
negotiating with him over really
important complicated divisive hard
issues negotiating over over nuclear
weapons and other weapons of mass
destruction is a really hard often
tedious process that involved a lot of
different agencies on our side and on
the living inside it wasn't just
something where Qaddafi sat at the table
and raised his hand up or down whether
something could go forward just engaging
Libya from the web of ties it had two
groups that we designated terrorist
organization organizations was
tremendous work this was a multi-year
process where the Libyans were fully
engaged and delivered every single thing
we wanted at the end every single thing
so at the outbreak of this current
conflict with Qaddafi one of the first
things that Qaddafi wants to do says
themselves as to his son other and other
envoys he wants the United Nations
Security Council to send monitors into
Libya to do a fact-finding mission we
laugh it off this is just propaganda he
just wants to you know use un monitors
just you know to have kind of this fake
this fake show of an ideal situation in
Libya he sends envoys to Europe to
negotiate with Europeans with us we
refuse to meet with the envoys because
again we don't want to beat you know we
don't want to stall for time and let
people be killed on the mass
heard on the ground well we're you know
sipping our tea and crumpets and
negotiating that's the mindset that
prevents us from negotiating but if we
actually did negotiate with Qaddafi as
we had previously i think there's no
reason to think based on the historical
record of Qadhafi's behavior that we
couldn't have come to negotiated some
sub negotiated settlement now does that
mean that Qaddafi would have been forced
from office maybe not doesn't mean that
he could have had some sort of internal
exile or power sharing may have been
hard but it may have been possible and I
think we would have saved an enormous
number of lives that way then through
this false paradigm that we can
intervene on the people's behalf so what
I think is critically important is for
us to really be looking at how we
demonize the other player so much so
that we make negotiation impossible and
what's dramatic in this situation is
that we actually because bahrain is
considered pro-american and would quote
unquote listen to us that's exactly what
Secretary Clinton said well King Hamid
listen to us they could have dialogue
even though they had also used
helicopters to shoot at their people
they had also killed people open fire
with live ammunition done a lot of the
same things that the Libyan did Libyans
did but because they would quote unquote
listen to us there in the pro-american
camp they get dialogue Libya is not they
get regime change we may see you know
some sort of victory in this where there
may be you know some kind of statue like
there was in 2003 that US soldiers or
other soldiers take down and some square
and come in Libya Gaddafi but I think it
will be really really short lived and
the consequences could be just as bad as
they have been from Iraq so to me it's
really really problematic to posit the
military intervention as an option where
I think it has some real drawbacks when
it's almost unimaginable for Americans
to think about negotiating so in those
last and the last part where I tried to
try out our options delivering on
arab-israeli peace would be ideal I
believe in that very strongly but short
of the ideal we can deliver in some
other ways or we could let others
deliver you know turkey and Venezuela
and again we do you mean Iseman as well
so that becomes problematic but at least
turkey have stepped forward as possible
mediators to what's going on in Libya we
have you know we've dismissed those
those options in the past not just with
Libya but with Iran last May the Turks
and the Brazilians came forward to
negotiate a resolution with with with
Iran over the nuclear issue they
succeeded they came up with a very good
negotiated document we just missed it
out of hand that's something that I
think has to fundamentally change and
that's what I'm really talking about in
terms of delivering delivering an
arab-israeli peace would be ideal I
think is necessary but short of that we
can deliver in some other areas so I
think it is really important and needs
to be unpacked needs to be unpacked more
on Syria it's tough to talk to one of
the world's leading experts on Syria two
of the world's leading experts sitting
right here not only of course has Ellen
less done brown groundbreaking research
there speaks fluent Syrian Arabic but
person needs to be next door is also
written a book about Syria so it's a
little tough to to speak about Syria in
that context but I will anyway things
could change in Syria but what I think
is important is that Bashar al-assad has
a political resource that some of his
some some of his fellow heads of state
do not have to draw on and that is the
political resource of having developed
carried on his father's legacy of
developing this really independent state
in Syria and keeping Syria together in a
unified secular way when it has so many
internal fissures and sectarian
divisions I think that many people in
Syria I think the majority not everybody
but the majority i think in Syria do not
want the country to be to be basically
at war in itself among sectarian among
the various sects I think that really
plays in Bashar al-assad's favor and I
think you saw the counter demonstrations
in Damascus in favor of Bashar al-assad
testament to the amount of investment
we'll have in the Syrian state now when
I when I've met with Bashar al-assad for
for various research interviews he has
really talked about the the motivating
cause for his for his for his politics
being to maintain Syria as a secular
unified state I think that has
tremendous resonance not only for his
you know his ethnic group for the Alawis
certainly for the Christians in Syria
and I think for a significant number of
the Sunni elite now that's not going to
be everybody in Syria there certainly is
a history in Syria dating back many many
decades of a very active Islamist
current in various various areas of the
country and given the opportunity
particularly in a Facebook generation
they have I think an opportunity to make
their voice heard I don't think it will
be a majority of the country and I think
there is enough of this vested interest
that Bashar al-assad could draw from now
I don't think he has some of the
potential safety valves that maybe some
others do to open the politics more if
he gives everybody you know the one man
one vote principle that's not
necessarily going to be in his favor I
don't think political reform is
something that's going to help solve his
problem but if he can push the narrative
of being uniquely capable of leaving the
state to stay unified and not and
basically non-sectarian in a very very
troubled universe in a very very
troubled neighborhood I think that's
something that has really served him
well and we've seen him come back like
his father we've seen both of them
really severely tested you know in 2005
Bashar al-assad was I think the
laughingstock of the region and in
Washington he was seen in Washington is
not just not just bad but not
intelligent people commonly referred to
him as the evil more on in Washington
and he was quite isolated in the region
but he fought back from that isolation
with I think this political drive of
Syria as an independent strategic
important player he was able to fight
back and really reverse that isolate
so that today he has these these really
strategically consequential
relationships not just with Iran but
with Turkey I think he's really fought
back in Lebanon he's essentially got the
Israelis on his side I mean you know we
read ha RS the Israeli newspaper they're
talking about how bad it would be a
bashar al-assad fell I mean this is
quite a turn of events for him and
similarly his father you know his father
didn't really become known as the Lion
of Damascus until both he put down the
internal challenge in Hama and he really
pushed back on the Israelis and the
Americans in Lebanon now maybe Bashar
al-assad will need to do that in Reverse
first he pushes back on the United
States and the French in international
politics and second he deals with the
attorney internal challenge I hope for
Syrians that he can deal with the
internal challenge in a less violent way
and I think he can but it will be a
challenge but I think he does have the
political resources to come through but
again it's a challenge I just don't
think that it's he's not facing the
overwhelming challenge and this is
sustained challenge and the massive
challenge that the other state the other
the pro-american states have taken and I
think that's in particular because he
doesn't he doesn't have to deal with the
problem of having taken a pro-american
line that was against the perceived
interests of his people please
that is a 64 million dollar question in
and it's you know particularly for
France of course it's a complete
reversal to where they were you know
just just less than a decade ago it is a
complete reversal I think some people
ascribe it to their personal politics of
Sarkozy others I think ascribe it to
kind of the dynamics of the European
Union having to remain relevant in an
international political system where
they are becoming both less relevant
less economically powerful and for
themselves in themselves less cohesive
that before the invasion of Iraq Europe
was really on its way to not only a
strong currency a very strong and
dominant economy but was really on its
way towards powerful political
integration you know that in the past
five years is come crashing down for the
Europeans and I think unfortunately
we've seen in European history that
often has them turn turn outward to
consolidate some of their political and
economic influence beyond their borders
but it still to me is a 64 million
dollar question they've done it today
with Libya but they even started really
doing it with Iran during the 2008
presidential campaign in this country
for the presidency it was quite striking
but during the campaign when when
then-candidate obama put out the idea of
strategic engagement with the Islamic
Republic of Iran British and French
diplomats from their embassies in
Washington met with Obama anes does it
what are you doing why are you reaching
out to Iran this isn't going to be good
this is this is counterproductive we
need to be standing together as one
cohesive political alignment against
Iran they were really interfering in an
American political campaign in a way
that I don't think we've seen for a very
very long time so I don't think it's a
sudden turn with Libya but it's
certainly a very dramatic turn with
Libya he remains to be seen to me
whether the president was whether
President Obama can sell their concerns
as a reason for the Americans to act in
another yet another military
intervention in a Muslim country I think
Obama will try to make that case tonight
I am I remain to be convinced but why
that dynamic is happening I think some
of it has to do with their political and
economic concerns inside Europe but it
really is a 64 million dollar question
please in the back human rights is I
think a very very important issue of
course we want and certainly as an
American I would like human rights in my
country to be impeccably respected and I
would like that every place else in the
world and I don't consider myself to
really be a relativist but I do consider
myself to be a realist and to look at
really situations on the ground as they
are and let me take one example in the
Islamic Republic of Iran I think it is
typically caricatured as a misogynist
political order that is very oppressive
toward women but if you look at just the
education statistics and if you go when
go to the Islamic Republic of Iran and
you look at women and girls in school
it's quite a dramatic story the number
of women and girls that have been
educated percentage-wise in the
population under the Islamic Republic of
Iran compared to under the Shah when you
had a clearly pro-american political
order what was looked looked like on the
outside as a liberal political order
where women didn't have to go with a
head covering the number of women and
then the percentage of women in there
among among women in the population was
relatively low compared to what it is
today and one of the reasons is that
women now who have to wear the facade
will have to be covered where the chador
their families particularly outside of
North char on are much more willing to
allow those girls to go to school to
allow those girls and then women to go
to university so today when you go to
the University of Tehran the majority of
the faculty members and students in the
majority of students and the faculty of
medicine are women many of the
department heads at the University of
jahar on our women it's really quite as
rounding to see that is not something
that you would have seen in the 1970s in
Iran so this idea that women are
oppressed because of the certain ones
that we have on it in some cases that's
that's very true but in some cases it
really defies conventional wisdom
because sometimes having the traditional
veneer of something we as Americans see
as as oppressive is not necessarily
oppressive in some ways that really
really matter and I think education is
one of those things that really really
matters to the advancement of women from
women's opportunities and for the family
because of an educated mother am a
mother is educated I think that not only
helps her helps her in her marriage
helps her in the family and helps her
children and this is something that i
think the Islamic Republic of Iran for
all of its flaws and I'm not here to say
that it's any kind of perfect society I
think it has some very significant flaws
but taking this issue of women i think
it is often used as a wedge issue but
when you look at those Education
Statistics I think it tells a very very
different story and well up to me
everything all credit goes to women in
almost every area I tell that to my
husband every day and absolutely i mean
the determination for women and girls to
go to school and to learn is absolutely
one hundred percent their their their
right to own that success for themselves
but it's something that every woman i
think does in partnership as part of a
family and if they're in a family that's
not going to let them go to school
because they're concerned about their
safety whether that's right or wrong
that's a problem and if that problem can
be addressed by them wearing the hijab
or the chador that's something that I
personally am NOT going to be against
I'm not going to stand in their way so I
just think it's a situation where you
have to look at each country and see
what they are and then see what is it
possible for the United States you do or
to not do so for example looking at
Afghanistan I think the idea that we
should send US troops into Afghanistan
to help the win
there is a very very problematic issue
very very problematic to force the
Afghans to change some of their cultural
and traditional ways of dealing with
women I think first of all is really
questionable whether it can happen and I
think the idea that they're going to
want to do it again this is the soft
power importance I think of Joseph nice
concept that they're going to want to do
this on behalf of their women and girls
because they're forced to do so you know
at the end at the from a bayonet on a
tank is really i think is nonsensical
and if you look at how it's played on
the ground you know i would i would
encourage people to read this month's is
it mother jones a rolling stone magazine
in Rolling Stone magazine there's really
very important article about yet again
US troops dealing with the civilian
population in a horrendous horrendous
way and the idea that that's somehow
going to produce benefits for women I
don't think makes sense and we shouldn't
really we shouldn't have any blinders on
you know one of the big things that the
United States did in terms of dealing
with them in on the ground was we gave
viagra to Afghan warlords that's not
going to help women on the ground in
Afghanistan so in that in that area in
particular I think we should not be
engaged and we should let different
societies different regions develop
their own ways at their own pace and we
should we should promote programs we
should promote education we should
promote the World Health Organization
vaccines health for the population and
you know that that will get to women as
it gets to women please
I think that's also a really good
question when I said that they could sit
on their hands and benefit reap the
benefits of what's happening in the
region it doesn't mean that they're not
involved I think they have a really
powerful narrative that makes them
absolutely involved in the dynamics of
the region and is helping to really
shift the balance of power in the soft
power way to their into it in a way that
is to their advantage what it means is
that it doesn't they're not doing it by
giving you know a rocket to Hamas here
or you know 10 Rockets to Hezbollah
there or a million dollars to this
person or that person it means that
they're really developing this soft
strategy of using a narrative that
appeals to populations beyond their
borders now here I think it's really
important and not to give a plug for our
book but I think it is really important
to look at realistically the national
security strategy of the Islamic
Republic of Iran typically Western
analysts have looked at Iran's national
security strategy and they anchor it
from the Shahs time and they kind of
come to today without that much that
much difference under the Shah I think
Iran had some real liabilities it is
largely a Shiite country and not Arab
those two pieces of of Iran's
composition I think made it very very
difficult for the shot to really project
any kind of soft power influence beyond
Iran's borders and therefore the Shah
had to really adopt more hard power you
know more hard power levers to deal with
other states and that's one part why he
was able to develop and cultivate a
relationship with Israel because it was
much more of a hard power relationship
what the Islamic Republic of Iran has
going for it which we I think all too
easily dismiss is that it is able to use
it
soft power to appeal beyond its Shia
identity beyond its Persian identity to
really get at the issues that Muslims
throughout the Middle East that Arabs
throughout the Middle East really care
about now in part it's hard for us to
see it because in part it's in language
that many Americans find offensive
videos with Israel ideas with the
Holocaust at deals 911 it deals with
issues that that we are just reflexively
very very concerned about so it's really
hard for us to hear but in the Middle
East particularly with off Medina job
but I think even going back throughout
the the establishment the Islamic
Republic of Iran we've seen this
steadily increase they are able to use
these this this this soft power this
narrative of championing championing
justice independence Palestine being
against the United States they're able
to really champion in a way that has
resonance beyond their hsieh and Persian
identities and I think that important is
really given the Islamic Republic this
soft power edge that was not available
to the Shah and why the Shah had to
really pursue much more of a hard power
strategy please
I think it does take a great president
and I think it does take a great
secretary of state and national security
advisor and I hate to say this because i
am a harvard-educated lawyer but I but
one of the great pleasures and benefits
of being at Yale in addition to kind of
working on these issues much more from a
political perspective political science
perspective really over the years has
been an understanding of how important
this kind of rigorous academic rounding
in political science and international
relations is we really need a strategist
in the White House we don't need a
lawyer whether that lawyer is a
Republican lawyer or Democratic lawyer
Democratic Party lawyer they just see
the issues and see the region very very
differently I mean you hear President
Obama as another harvard-trained lawyer
saying that you know we had a good
process he heard this person's view in
that person's view and he came to this
decision as if he's some Solomon like
judge but that's not a strategist he
might be fair he may be inclusive he may
have a variety of different views at the
table but that's not a strategist and
his national security advisor is the
same way and we had that under Clinton I
think it's a serious problem that we've
really invested the our farm policy
strategy to lawyers and again I say that
against my own interest but I think
there is really a different analytic
approach now you could have I think a
strategist who's not really a great
strategist and I would have some
criticisms of some American Secretary of
State's and national security advisers
and presidents who were not lawyers and
were poor strategist but i do think one
of the things that's necessary is this
really rigorous study either in in
academia or just on their own at least a
really rigorous study of international
relations and great power politics and
to come from that with a real strategy
understanding of what US interests are
how they can be achieved what the limits
are for what we can achieve that is
crucial and I think that's something
that of course Kissinger is the
embodiment of and in what you know
there are many negatives of what
Kissinger did many problems with what he
did but I think the overall strategic
approach that he put on the table
enabled him to carry out one of the
greatest diplomatic accomplishments in
American history the u.s. opening to
China I cannot see now with the current
constellation of policymakers we have
any one of them really thinking that
through and understanding how necessary
and that is with the Islamic Republic of
Iran but it is absolutely necessary and
if you know I have to make this argument
and I have been asked to make this
argument when you have to you know write
ten books about it I think we'll do that
because it really is critically
important for the United States not only
to restore credibility in our standing
in the middle east but that is so
important for our global standing we
will not be a global power if we do not
have the balance of power right in the
middle east in our favor that is just a
requirement for our global standing and
I think there's just too much at stake
but unfortunately I think it does
require people in the White House to
really be strategist foreign policy
strategists please
why would I would focus really on some
of the comments that I had at the end at
the end of my top that I think we should
really be looking at delivering benefits
being seen as their purveyor of benefits
of good in the region and then that
plays out in different ways that could
play out trying to deliver a resolution
of the core the region's poor conflict
the arab-israeli conflict that could
play out as it has over the decades in
providing security for the region that
could play out in terms of providing
human security on the ground through
negotiation with governments and publix
it could play out in a variety of ways
but i think the overarching strategy is
to be delivering something good for
people on the ground rather than being
perceived as part of the problem that
regional governments have to support us
against their people but essentially is
what they have to do now whether it's in
helping us with our rendition program to
get to basically take Arab citizens
anywhere in the world to bring back to
their country to be tortured for
information for the United States to use
that's not something that is seen is a
good on the ground in the Middle East
it's not such you know 24 regional
governments to have to work with us with
the Israelis to continue the siege of a
civilian population in Gaza that's not
perceived as a good on the ground in the
region we would need to change some of
those things to perceive be perceived as
not being a problem not being part of a
problem for Arab public's and do
something to replace that that's
something good that they can see is a
good that would prove that would help i
think rehabilitate our legitimacy the
legitimacy of our purpose in the region
to deliver in some way on those benefits
and the other critical piece of the
strategy would be to balance to allow
the powers in the region the natural
powers in the region to emerge as the
natural powers that they are for us to
have constructive strategic relations
with each of them and have them balanced
amongst themselves so that it's not just
us versus whatever power is on the
ground means that we're not constantly
in a situation where we have to try to
take out the emerging big power whether
it's Iraq or Iran or now even Libya
we're we're not in a position to have to
always try to take out the Challenger to
the pro-american political order there's
an order on the ground that is balancing
among amongst itself that where the
powers are balancing amongst themselves
to me that is the real great challenge
in our diplomacy to allow these powers
to emerge us to have a strategic
relation with relationship with each of
them and for them to balance amongst
themselves I think it actually is
principally about Iran and principally
about although President Obama puts
forward this is very bold and I think
critically important concept of
strategic engagement with the Islamic
Republic of Iran he eventually dismisses
that dish's it throws it away after the
elections they are in june 2009 and
essentially does with with what he did
with Libya with Qaddafi but he doesn't
say it explicitly but essentially does
the same thing that can't negotiate with
them that regime is just it's just a
question of what it's going to go it's
got to go and so all the negotiations
that we've had with them I think are
just going through the motions as well
on this slow trajectory towards conflict
with the Islamic Republic of Iran so I
think it's about not wanting to have an
effective agreement with them at this
point and it's one of the it ends up
being very distorting in the politics
and the actual tactics of what goes on
so distorting that it becomes even
dishonest at times so just a month
before I think three weeks or a month
before
the Turkish and Brazilian heads of state
go to Iran to negotiate this agreement
President Obama writes a letter to them
both to Lula and Brazil and to Iran and
Turkey where he you know he's basically
says it's going to be very difficult to
negotiate with the Iranians but you know
if you need to do that these are the
things that have to be in the agreement
he spells them out one two three very
clearly very explicitly lo and behold
Lula and erdo on take that letter they
go you know by the letter of that letter
and the negotiated an agreement that
includes everything that as President
Obama laid out in the letter they get
the agreement what happens the Obama
administration is put in the ridiculous
position of having to say that a press
letter from the President of the United
States doesn't represent US policy it's
a ridiculous position if not outright
dishonest and I think you end up being
that way not because people are bad
people in the White House not because
they're naturally dishonest but because
the processes now become so distorting
because it's really about designating
Iran just as we've designated Libya as
an outlier state that cannot be part of
a pro-american political and security
order and it has to do with our
consideration at this point of their
internal politics we're not saying is
it's possibly on Iran because there's
much more at stake with Iran we're
saying its facility with Libya but I
think it's the same thing that's at
stake and we will continue to see this
kind of distortion in the politics
bordering on the on the dishonest